Snooki told us for her and Jionni
divorce is not an option do you feel
like you and Roger live by that same
mentality no no cuz their third
deal-breakers in our relationship
Jenni Farley aka JWoww has a pretty
serious message for estranged husband
Roger Matthews the Jersey Shore star
shared a very heated open letter on her
website Wednesday addressed to Roger
who's been publicly feuding with her
since she filed for divorce in September
my ex cannot control her emotions in
front of our children and and literally
turns my child against me JWoww also
posted a handful of disturbing videos
which appear to show the pair fighting
and things get physical
et reached out to a rep for Roger who
told us quote at this time we will not
be giving a comment on this matter but
on Thursday Roger took to Instagram to
deny JWoww's claims we're gonna address
this in court which is the proper place
to address it we've proven genuine our
attorneys to be liars in the past and we
will do it again my concern is my
children and I will not stop until I
have my children
JWoww's letter starts by saying she
tried to resolve their issues out of the
spotlight for the sake of their children
but now she says quote I can no longer
sit idly by while you mistreat and
malign me JWoww claims roger has been
doing a number of harmful things
including sharing false statements and
endangering their children quote you are
an abuser to the core Roger Mathews if
this was not enough you have spit at me
you have pushed me you have shoved me
you have aggressively thrown me to the
ground
you have belittled and disparaged me
JWoww ended her post by sharing several
court documents alleged text messages
and videos supporting her claims et sat
down with a reality star in September
2016 when she candidly addressed the ups
and downs in her then marriage to Roger
third deal-breakers in our relationship
that we would separate over I think
yeah I like the cheating or you know
Affairs things like that things that you
can't go back like you can't go back in
time and fix coz like what I always say
like when the damage is done it's done
but yeah I would never say it's not an
option because if you're truly unhappy
you shouldn't stay in a relationship